All right so I just written
out our equation for Q' and
substituted in the definitions
that we think are true.
What the new Q' is in
terms of the old Q and
what the new rewards are in
terms of the old rewards.
And so if this works.
If we can do a bunch of if and only ifs
that actually bring us to something that
we know is true then we should be good.
>> Okay.
>> So
>> All right how can we,
we do have an equation for Q.
We don't have an equation for
Q minus psi of s.
But maybe we can cancel some things?
>> Oh,
I can see two things we can cancel.
>> All right.
>> Okay, so the first psi of s on
the left side of the equals sign?
>> Yep.
>> That matches up with the first
psi of s right next to r.
Yes, right there.
>> Yeah, because we're summing this
over all next states, all next S'.
And this sums up to 1,
it's a convex combination.
>> Right, so that means,
effectively you could take it out.
It doesn't depend on S' anyway.
And they go away.
Good, so now we got Q(s,a) on one side.
And then you can actually
handle the next one.
If you look at the next psi of S'.
The gamma of psi S'.
Well that matches with
the minus gamma of S'
inside the max because that
max is multiplied by a gamma.
>> Good.
Right.
Right, right, right.
Yeah, so it's interesting.
And the max itself is not impacted
by this quantity because it doesn't
depend on a prime.
It is in fact a constant.
>> So
we can actually take out this constant.
And it actually cancels this one.
And look what we're left with.
>> The original equation.
>> Ta da.
We're left with the original Q equation,
which we know is true and
so this is true if and
only if the original thing is true.
This is an actual solution
to the Q equation.
The Bellman equation and so, right,
this is what happens to the q function.
It's the old q function shifted
down by the potential function.
>> Right.
And at no point do we divide by zero, so
everything is great.
>> Right.
And how do we know that we still
have the same optimal policy?
>> In which case?
So we know we have some optimal
policy for this Q function.
This new Q function Q prime
has an optimal policy.
How do we know it's the same?
>> Well because it's just
the original Q function and
you're just being shifted
around by a constant and so
it doesn't change the max and therefore
it doesn't change the optimal policy.
>> Exactly.
Awesome.
All right, so this now gives us
three total different ways of
messing around with rewards
to give us new q functions that
don't actually change the policy.
>> That's really nice.
So, I have a question.
>> Sure.
>> You didn't
write anything down here about any
restrictions on the potential function.
>> That's right.
>> Does there have to be any
restrictions on the potential functions?
Maybe potential
restrictions potentially?
>> [LAUGH] I'm going to say no because
it is all going to end up being okay and
cancelling out.
So, there is a sense that
you've actually not changed
anything by throwing in one of these
additional potential functions.
Maybe it can help us learn faster?
Here, let's look at an example
where this might matter.
>> Okay.